[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la théorie quantique des champs
contrairement à une bille qui possède
une position définie à l'échelle
microscopique une particule n'a pas
vraiment de position sa présence est
distribuée à travers l'espace avec plus
ou moins de probabilité cette
description des particules par des ondes
de probabilité
ce qu'on appelle la mécanique quantique
la mécanique quantique permet de décrire
l'évolution d'une particule au cours du
temps mais cette description aussi
efficace soit elles manquent de prendre
en compte de considérations
d'une part la mécanique quantique ne
permet pas de décrire des situations où
le nombre de particules varie au cours
du temps pourtant dans la nature on
observe qu'elles peuvent apparaître ou
disparaître
par exemple quand un photon est absorbé
par un électron dans un atome
d'autre part la mécanique quantique
traite chaque particule comme si elle
était unique indépendante
pourtant au sein d'une même famille de
particules par exemple les électrons
tout exhibe les mêmes propriétés
comment se fait-il qu'un électron en
provenance des confins du cosmos possède
exactement la même masse et charge qu'un
électron dans une pomme pour répondre à
cette question il va nous falloir
construire un nouveau cadre
mathématiques une description plus
général qui réconcilie mécanique
quantique et relativité restreinte
il s'agit du cadre le plus précis pour
décrire notre monde microscopique
dans cette vidéo nous allons construire
ensemble la théorie quantique des champs
pour commencer unissons-nous d'un
univers vide la relativité nous enseigne
que le tissu de l'univers l espace temps
pour simplifier on représentera
seulement deux dimensions des espaces
ainsi que la dimension du temps on
souhaite désormais remplir notre univers
avec un contenu de la matière on a vu
précédemment que toutes les particules
d'un même type
par exemple tous les électrons semble
parfaitement identiques comme s'il ne
s'agissait que de manifestations locales
d'un seul et même objet sous jacent qui
remplirait tout l'univers un champ pour
ajouter un contenu un autre univers on
va donc commencer par le remplir d'un
champ en mathématiques un chant est une
sorte de fluides qui remplit tout
l'espace temps et dont chaque point est
peuplé par un objet mathématique
il peut s'agir d'un champ de nombre de
vecteurs ou d'autres objets plus
exotiques
cela dit la relativité restreinte impose
des restrictions
elle nous oblige à respecter certaine
symétrie qui correspondent à la
géométrie de l'espace temps les
symétries de translation de rotation ou
encore de changement de référentiel
c'est symétrie ne sont respectés que par
certains objets mathématiques et on peut
les classifier avec un paramètre c'est
leur spin les objets les plus simples
qui sont autorisés sont les nombres on
leur attribue le spin 0 car lorsqu'on
fait tourner l'espace autour d'un nombre
ne varie pas les vecteurs quant à eux
indique une direction dans l'espace et
leur apparence dépend de l'orientation
selon laquelle on les observe
on leur attribue le spin 1 car lorsqu'on
fait tourner l'espace d'un tour complet
un vecteur décrit lui aussi un tour
complet
enfin la relativité autorise également
d'autres objets plus exotiques et en
particulier les spinners de spin 1/2
il faut faire deux tours autour d'un
szpiner pour le retrouver dans son état
initial
[Musique]
tous ces objets mathématiques peuvent
sembler abstrait et certains difficile à
comprendre mais à priori ils obéissent
tous au symétrie de la relativité et
sont donc des candidats potentiels parmi
lesquels piocher pour remplir notre
univers en plus d'imposer les types
d'objets qui sont autorisés les
symétries de l'espace-temps vont
également restreindre la façon dont
s'agencent les objets à l'intérieur du
champ
chaque symétrie oblige le champ à
respecter la conservation d'une certaine
grandeur au cours du temps pour obéir la
relativité notre champ doit respecter la
conservation de l'énergie de la quantité
de mouvements du moment cinétique et de
la vitesse du centre de masse
[Musique]
de plus les objets mathématiques peut
même peuvent contenir des symétries qui
leur sont propres
si on décide de former un champ avec des
nombreux complexes par exemple ceux ci
contiennent une symétrie interne qui
implique la conservation d'une autre
grandeur au cours du temps liées à la
nature des nombres complexes la charge
électrique à cette étape on dispose d'un
espace temps que l'on a rempli par un
chant qui satisfait toutes les
restrictions imposées par la relativité
restreinte mais notre objectif est de
décrire le monde microscopique et les
donc temps de transformer notre champ en
un chant quantique
[Musique]
en mécanique quantique pour transformer
un objet classique en objet quantique on
l'autorisé à adopter plusieurs positions
en même temps avec plus ou moins de
probabilités de façon analogue pour
transformer un chant classique en chant
quantique
on va l'autorisé à adopter plusieurs
configurations plusieurs possibilités
d'évolution avec plus ou moins
d'importance au cours du temps notre
champ évolue dans une superposition de
tous les scénarios possibles le passage
d'un chant classique un champ quantique
entraîne une propriété très intéressante
un peu comme un électron dans un atome
qui possèdent des niveaux d'énergie bien
précis un chant quantique possède lui
aussi des niveaux d'énergie
il ne peut contenir qu'un nombre entier
de perturbation des quantas d'énergie
qui peuvent apparaître ou disparaître
ce sont des particules un peu comme une
vague à la surface de l'eau une
particule est simplement une
perturbation qui se propage à
l'intérieur du champ
[Musique]
un chant quantique est également agité
de fluctuation qui ne cessent
d'apparaître et de disparaître
c'est ce qu'on appelle des particules
virtuelles ces particules virtuelles
n'existe que très brièvement
de sorte qu'il est strictement
impossible de les observer
peu à peu notre modèle d'univers se
rapproche de la réalité
on décrit désormais un espace temps
rempli d'un champ quantique à
l'intérieur duquel se déplacent des
perturbations des particules dans une
soupe de fluctuation des particules
virtuelles dans notre univers coexistent
plusieurs chants qui constitue
différentes familles de particules
certains sont des chants de vecteurs de
spin 1 et les particules qu'ils
contiennent sont les photons lé boson z
et w et les gluants d'autres sons des
chants de spinner de spin 1/2 ce sont
les fermions qui composent la matière
quark électrons muons ton et neutrinos
enfin il existe un champ de spin 0 c'est
le chant de x parmi tous ces chants la
plupart possèdent des symétries interne
qui leur confère des grandeurs conserver
au cours du temps ce sont des charges
qui distingue leur particule en
plusieurs versions on a vu précédemment
que les champs de nombreux complexes
possède une symétrie qui leur confère la
charge électrique
cette symétrie va également séparés leur
particule en deux versions une de charge
positive l'autre de charge négative on
parle d'antimatière en quelque sorte une
antiparticule est le complexe conjugué
d'une particule ordinaire
certains champs exhibe des symétries
plus exotiques les champs de quark par
exemple qui possède une autre charge la
charge de couleurs qui doit elle aussi
être conservé au cours du temps et qui
permet de distinguer les quarks en trois
versions qu'on nomme rouge vert et bleu
l'ensemble de tous ces chants qui
constitue le contenu de notre univers
le modèle standard de la physique des
particules à l'heure actuelle il s'agit
de la description de notre univers la
mieux vérifier à l'échelle microscopique
[Musique]
notre modèle d'univers contient
désormais les mêmes particules que notre
univers réel
cela dit il n'est toujours pas réaliste
les symétries de la relativité oblige
les particules à s'y déplacer tout droit
indéfiniment et indépendamment les unes
des autres pour finalement compléter
notre modèle d'univers il ne nous reste
plus qu'à ajouter un seul ingrédient
fondamental on doit autoriser les champs
à interagir entre eux pour comprendre
concentrons-nous sur l'une des
interactions les plus simples celle
entre le champ des photons et celui des
électrons on va autoriser un électron à
émettre ou absorber un photon virtuel et
vice versa
autoriser cette simple interactions va
avoir des conséquences drastiques
par exemple dans la situation suivante
on commence avec deux électrons immobile
au cours du temps les deux électrons
avance vers le futur a priori on
pourrait penser que les deux électrons
reste immobile indéfiniment
mais ce serait oublier que nos électrons
baigne constamment dans le champ des
photons avec lequel on les a autorisés à
interagir
on a vu qu'un chant quantique réalise
toutes les évolutions possibles
en même temps avec plus ou moins
d'amplitude en quelque sorte chaque
configuration décrit un scénario et en
particulier dans certains de ces
scénarios
les électrons vont interagir avec le
chant des photons dans ce scénario par
exemple l'électron émettent un photon
virtuel un certain instants qui emporte
avec lui une partie du mouvement de
l'électron est le photon virtuel est
absorbé un peu plus tard par l'autre
électron
[Musique]
dans cet autre scénario des électrons
s'échange cette fois ci deux photons
virtuel ou encore dans ce troisième
scénario plus complexe
l'électron émettent un photon virtuel
qui se convertit en une paire électron
positron virtuel qui vont s'annihiler en
ans nous vos photos virtuelles qui est
enfin absorbé par le deuxième électrons
[Musique]
en s'échangeant une partie de leurs
mouvements grâce aux particules
virtuelles les deux électrons vont
parfois se rapprocher et parfois
s'éloigner
[Musique]
prenons l'analogie suivante sur une
guitare une corde peut vibrer avec
différentes fréquences qui correspondent
chacune un son pur mais lorsqu'on pense
la corde
celle ci se met à vibrer dans une
superposition de toutes ces fréquences
avec plus ou moins d'amplitude
c'est la synthèse de tous ces sons purs
qui s'additionnent avec plus ou moins
d'amplitude qui constitue le sang total
produit par la corde
de façon analogue un champ quantique
évolue selon tous les scénarios
possibles avec plus ou moins d'amplitude
et c'est la synthèse de tous ces
scénarios ensemble qui décrit
l'évolution réelle du système physique
en particulier dans notre exemple
lorsqu'on additionne toutes ses
possibilités
on observe que globalement nos deux
électrons s'éloigne peu à peu ils
ressentent une force qui les repoussent
à cause des échanges de photos
virtuelles
c'est la force électromagnétique
et si l inverse on avait commencé avec
un électron et un positon de charges
opposées les amplitudes des différents
scénarios auraient été différentes
résultat cette fois ci en une force
globale attractive en autorisant les
particules à interagir et à s'échanger
leurs mouvements
la théorie quantique des champs explique
comment les forces émergent à partir de
simples symétrie les symétries deschamps
qui constitue notre univers pour
conclure la théorie quantique des champs
est une recette mathématiques pour
construire un modèle d'univers on part
d'un espace temps que l'on remplit avec
des chants quantique qui satisfont les
symétries de la relativité restreinte
la théorie quantique des champs permet
ainsi de construire une description
quantique de notre univers qui respecte
les restrictions imposées par la
relativité en autorisant les champs à
interagir les uns avec les autres
cette théorie permet de prédire avec une
précision stupéfiante les phénomènes qui
régissent notre univers
selon la théorie quantique des champs
l'évolution de notre univers est en
quelque sorte la synthèse de tous les
scénarios possibles à l'échelle
microscopique
ceci dit cette description reste
incomplète car même si elle satisfait la
relativité restreinte
la théorie quantique des champs ne peut
pas être unifiée avec la relativité
générale qui décrit la gravitation par
la courbure de l'espace temps certains
résultats de la théorie peuvent d'ores
et déjà être appliquée à des
espaces-temps courbes comme par exemple
la prédiction que les trous noirs
s'évapore au cours du temps mais les
scientifiques sont à la recherche d'une
théorie unique qui permettrait
d'expliquer fondamentalement d'où
provient cette courbure et qui
unifierait l'infiniment grand et
l'infiniment petit une théorie du tout
[Musique]